dix mois alors on a vu un petit peu
toute ta vie ton de son premier enfant
ton deuxième enfant le deuxième en
france c'était philippe n'a pas
travaillé de ma naissance
non on n'a pas parlé de sa passion tu
veux qu'on en parle comme une procédure
pour chaque chiot avec les viols vous
n'êtes pas mariée finalement toi tu
voulais te marier mais l église et lui
voulaient pas c'est à dire que moi j'ai
toujours eu un rêve et déjà j'avais fini
par aller voir le curé de saint sulpice
à ce sujet ouais parce que j'aurais
voulu me marier elle est c'est à dire
céré monie sans mariage me marier à
l'église sans passer par la mairie parce
que la mairie c'est que des papiers et
des problèmes des emmerdes tandis que
l'église effectivement ses travers après
je suis allé voir le curé je lui dis
voilà séparation de l'église et de
l'état
ç'a eu lieu en 1950 normalement rien ne
s'oppose mais oui mathilde et rien ne
s'oppose donc je veux en principe va
pouvoir se marier j'ai bien regretter ça
alors là oui l'europe centrale est
assurée pour kaba voulu au final car il
était d'abord parce que j'étais un peu
hâte et quand même au dessus dont amiens
mais j'ai tout fait pour me marier dans
l'immédiat c'était pour avoir un
enseignement dans 85 après ça faisait
quoi six ans de vie commune
vous avez décidé de faire un appartement
à part non mais c'est vrai que si on
parle du problème des diverses en
général c'est vrai que moi je pense que
on devra dire vote ont fait des gosses
on en prend pour 25 ans et puis que
effectivement des deux appartements
lancent chacun de son côté d'un palier
ou deux étages différents sites une
solution il y avait une petite fille de
parents divorcés qui disait le moi j'en
ai marre
pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas moi qui
suis dans l'appartement api vous qui
venez chacun votre famille c'est vrai le
sco pas mal mais oui c'est le terry pour
les enfants d'avoir déménagé papa la
maman là et c'est bon tu es content le
divorce en gros c'est à dire je ne suis
pas contre que chacun reprenne sa vie
privée et puis j'ai en effet je trouve
que c'est mieux
oui de jolo dicté contre l'idée de
rester à nicolas pour et moi les enfants
semblent contre l'idée de massacrer des
enfants pour découvrir de petits
plaisirs qui est finalement finiront par
s'user à leur tour
ce que je trouve c'est que ya deux
façons de voir les choses ya la bonne
vision française
lisant française de toute l'époque
classique on disait de valence marie
c'est pour élever les enfants puis si on
s'entend pas bon on fait chacun chambres
ont fait chambre à part et on a sa vie
et puis on développe est jaloux
s'emmerder avec des histoires et on a
des enfants c'est ça qu'on sait déjà
faire et aux essais ça veut dire quoi
alors divorce alors on recommence et de
nouveau le grand amour et on refait des
enfants et puis bon le grand amour la
passion chérie je t'aime c'est pour
l'avion c'est très bien c'est pourquoi
trois ans est en disant non et puis
c'est tout alors puisqu'on sait pour
compte et tout ça tu aimes tu es enfant
tu as un petit peu sacrifié sa carrière
annonce a dit ou jielin quand même un
petit peu sacrifié ta carrière pour
qu'elle vive dans le bordelais parce que
c'est pour eux qu'elle est vive dans le
bordelais mais c'est beaucoup pour moi
mais malgré tout c'est à dire que c'est
vrai que les enfants qui décident des
carrés pour eux on leur dit des signes
impressions et des films l'écart et
année malgré tout tu dis quand même que
tes enfants bon maintenant que tu les as
tu fais tout pour eux tu veux tu aller
vivre dans le bordelais un petit peu
pour eux mais malgré ce que tu dis que
tu les a eus par accident ses enfants tu
dis que tu as été victime du mythe de la
femme reproductrices à qui on explique
depuis qu'elle est toute petite qu'elle
doit avoir des enfants c'est vrai que
les femmes autres voire z faisait des
enfants affiche n'est pas dans mon média
on est un set up on faisait les enfants
pour qui la pilule est arrivé et puis
mais la pilule est arrivé mais les
mentalités ont continué à être pour être
une femme et pour tout le monde s'y être
une vraie femme je dire toutes les
femmes ont fait les enfants alors que si
on commence à élever les filles
différemment en leur disant qu'ils aient
atteint sur les enfants c'est un boulot
c'est une vocation c'est très
particulier à temps complet un travail à
temps complet qui demande un tas de
compétences qui demandent du causse y
adonnent qu'on se passionne pour cette
serra alors donc réfléchi mais on peut
aussi envisager d'ailleurs de dire défi
qui dit moi je les fais puis c'est
d'autres fixent les élèves comme par
exemple les africains qui vivent tribu
ça fait des enfants 13 qui libérait pas
s'ils ont toutes sortes de ya plein de
gens autour d'eux donc ils peuvent
choisir avec qui vont se sentant qui va
leur apporter tout ça mais c'est vrai
que la façon dont on vit en ville avec
les femmes au budo les mecs qui malgré
tout
100 en foot ou tout à fait rien pour mon
faux pas grand chose et que eux et le
pit le manque de crèches les horaires et
les mecs ils disent qu'ils mettent la
main à la pâte mais il paraît qu'ils
faisaient de leur bonne femme dix
minutes de plus 400 ans
je savais ce n'est qu'à 20 ans on
m'avait dit qu'en 20 ans du sionisme
hurle la diminution guérite de plus les
minutes ou les vingt ans ça fait pas
lourd
cheney en commun ils vont pas content tu
as dit que tu avais avorté tu lui a
déclaré sans beaucoup de l'immobilité
d'ailleurs tu dis que c'est un petit peu
comme tuer des des petits chatons ça
fait froid dans le dos non mais je vous
dis ah non mais c'est à dire que parce
que moi j'ai connu quand même l'époque
où c'est interdit
alors bon c'est vrai qu'on a après on
dit un provoque pas exagérer je vis
seule la et un nom je veux je suis
mariée mais les guides j'aimerais bien
j'ai lancé un appel sur les ondes
j'aimerais bien un jour être demoiselle
d'honneur se dit dans ma génération il
n'y a pas un homme pour rejeter l'autre
tu vois que tu vas rester célibataire
longtemps je n'ai parlé de ma génération